pourquoi donc la structure surélevée la
dernière fois qu'on se mettait par les
ibères si tout est placé à côté on fait
des parcs et tout ça ça peut être
intéressant dans le fond vous l'avez
jamais acheté là mais j'ai surtout envie
de vous dire que malgré tout ce qui est
ressorti leur parlant trop de rapport
d'expert un kid et mettaient plusieurs
préoccupations et malgré toute la bonne
volonté de la cdpq un froch beaucoup
amélioré son projet et on demeurait pas
moins des gros gros héritant entre
autres avec le tracé aérien au centre
ville et canton écouter les experts les
citoyens puis quand je prends les
experts autant en urbanisme en transport
qui disait mais on peut pas faire une
structure pareil au centre ville de
montréal à un moment donné il faut se
rendre à l'évidence mais moi ce que je
voulais éviter ce bébé avec l'eau du
bain c'est ça que je voulais éviter web
et je vais en parler du bébé que du vin
dans une seconde mais sur la structure
pour vous société une condition qui
faisait que ça marche et paul c'est un
élément qui faisait que ça allait pas
marcher jamais on la regardait tous
bords de côté mais au final serait peut
être bon marché mais vous aviez pas du
seul et pas vraiment parce que justement
une fois que le rapport des experts est
un sportif on a pris le temps quand je
vous dit de regarder tous bords tous
côtés de se dire ça peux tu marchais est
ce que ça peut fonctionner puis la
réponse au final c'est non quand on veut
sauver patrimoine je pense au quartier
chinois canton 2 au parc morgan quand on
veut s'assurer que l'on fasse pas une
cicatrice sur ben et c'est ça que ça
faisait alors on n'a pas le choix on
voit les images pendant que vous parlez
de cette structure qui n'existera jamais
blanche est-ce que yapo je me fais
l'avocat du diable y'a pas un manque
d'imagination
puis on se dit d'abord que ça marchera
jamais avant de le faire et de l'essayer
parceque il y aura pas de lien direct
entre l'est de montréal centre-ville
c'est ça que ça veut dire écoutez deux
choses la première c'est quand vous
dites est ce qu'on aurait elle fait
qu'il essayait on s'entasse quand même
un investissement de 10 milliards de
dollars taxes et pas comme un projet
pilote à temps on le fait depuis on est
pogné avec si je peux dire pendant les
cent prochaines années et c'est sûr que
nous on regarde à l'étranger on voyait
que toutes les grandes villes en général
met les structures au sol on voit très
peu de grandes villes qui vont monter
des structures parce que la possibilité
que ce soient vandalisés
que ce soit moins sécuritaire que ça
crée une fracture sont grandes je ne dis
pas qu'elles sont insurmontables sont
extrêmement grande et pour ce qui est du
lien c'est pour ça que lorsque j'ai pris
le téléphone pour parler que le premier
ministre la chose que je lui ai dit
c'est gardons ce qui fonctionne les deux
branches est énorme mais il faut
absolument des renforcer la ligne verte
qui va être notre notre façon de rentrer
au centre de rentrer au centre-ville de
façon rapide on va peut-être le voir sur
la carte vous vous souhaitez garder
le transport delhaize qui se brancherait
sur la ligne verte exactement exactement
qui est un enjeu on se rappellera
lorsque les experts ont sorti leur à
part un des choses qui a été très
critiquée c'est aussi ça ça ne se
parlaient pas on avait le réel de l'est
qui on avait la ligne verte il n'y avait
aucune connexion si dans quinze ans la
ligne verte on arrive à la conclusion
que c'est ce que disait là qu'est ce que
c'est saturé lannic verte on fait quoi
parce qu'il faut voir un projet en
transport en commun pour les 25 ans est
ce que ça donne une courte vue de dire
on branche la ligne verte l'effet
d'immersion écoutez c'est sûr qu'on peut
dire et si et si et si mais au moment où
on en était sûrs roi c'était une
question de ça passe ou ça casse et le
ce projet-là n'allait pas survivre sur
le garder dans la forme actuelle parce
que maman données c'est ben beau on peut
pas enfoncés dans fond de la gorge d'un
projet dont la population et même les
experts ne veulent pas pour juste pour
le centre-ville à on a les mains ce que
dans mercier hochelaga maisonneuve où il
y avait énormément de réticences mais je
le redis de pour moi et pour le premier
ministre c'est là où ça a cliqué pour
nous deux c'est de se dire on va tout
faire pour que le transport dans l'est
mais on va pas on veut pas perdre cet
investissement est là dessus parce que
j'ai rarement vu j'ai vu des bouts de la
conférence de presse mais vous étiez
heureux heureusement premier mais
heureux jamais on a eu l'impression que
courant aussi bien passé oui vous avez
raison je pense que oui et même belle
communion c'est pas une si bonne
nouvelle parce que là vous allez être
maître vous allez participer à ce projet
là mais convient à 0 mais non c'est à
fait honnêtement pour moi là aujourd'hui
je vous le dis là pour moi cette
victoire puis je voudrais vous regardant
dans les yeux parce que dans un an si on
faisait rien ce projet là allait mourir
au chapitre c'était évident parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'acceptabilité sociale
pour une grande partie du tracé puis en
plus avec la cdpq en fait le
gouvernement prend les travaux la cdpq
alors tout ce qui a été fait tout ce qui
était développé dès demain exactement
exactement c'est la bonne chose à faire
donc on ne peut pas absolument pas de
zéro et finalement ce que je veux vous
dire qu'il clib redessiné quiberon où
seront expertise pour dessiner un projet
et qu absolument donc moi j'ai envie de
vous dire que le fait que ça revienne à
la rtm comme le gouvernement le mandaté
pour moi c'est la bonne chose à faire et
la rtm la ville de montréal la stm et
gouvernement du québec verra ça en fait
du monde autour de la table du conseil
oui mais j'ai envie de prendre la
laverie neuf jeux jean luc soler vous
avez raison mais regardez juste là à la
ligne bleue ça faisait des décennies
qu'elle était bloquée on ait réussi à la
faire débloquer à peu près six mois
parce qu'on a mis ses quatre acteurs
locaux autour de la table on a décidé de
parler de captation foncières on ne
décide de revoir les paramètres et moi
je suis convaincu que projets publics
comme celui qu'on va faire avec le rm de
l'est va fonctionner mais je vous
cacherais pas que j'avais j'ai envie que
le gouvernement donne par exemple à ce
projet l'un des leviers similaire par
exemple à la cdpq là qui peut faire des
expropriations qui il faut qu'on se
donne les moyens ni absolument très bien
on verra la chambre de commerce de l'est
de montréal est déçu aujourd'hui qu'un
il y aura un vrai transport digne de ce
nom collectif anglais spill centre-ville
on regarde on honnêtement le premier
c'est mon le dis on garde le même
échéant si on avait bien vu exactement
c'est peut-être une question de mois de
plus de la même façon que leurs on
devait aller au banc au printemps le
bébé était prévu pour après les
élections on a déjà perdu quelques mois
mais je peux vous dire que pour nous
notre objectif c'est exactement le même
calendrier à quelques mois près pas à
quelques années près alors à quelques
mois près
on va voir oui j'aimerais vous croire
sur parole mais soyons vous comprenez
pourquoi on peut être c'est l'imam et je
veux combattre ceux signés cela parce
que le projet qu'on propose aujourd'hui
en ayant acquis bien planifiée et qui va
répondre aux besoins on garde ce qui
fonctionne et on laisse de côté ce qui
fonctionne pas la mairesse on va suivre
ça c'est une grosse journée suivante
j'avais une grosse décision et vous
dites fait deux semaines que c'est réglé
à la minute oui c'est un beau fruité
saviana moi je suis très fier quand je
vous dis un moment donné il faut prendre
des décisions qui sont difficiles mais
qui sont les bonnes et pour l'avenir de
la métropole c'était vraiment la bonne
et ça en france j'en suis convaincu
valérie plan merci d'être venu nous voir